good morning my name is Tara van Sol and
this is a talk called
learning to love JavaScript I'm not
entirely sure why any of you are here
when there are so many other great talks
going on right now but in any case thank
you for being here I'm very happy to see
you all and I hope that this will be a
worthwhile talk maybe you're here
because you love JavaScript and want to
affirm your feelings
maybe you've recently had some bad
thoughts about JavaScript and are
seeking redemption or maybe you're just
a full blown JavaScript hater and you're
here in anticipation of a rowdy Q&A
session those are all valid reasons to
be here except there will not be a Q&A
session today the organizers gave me the
option to spend the last 10 minutes
doing Q&A or talking at you for an extra
10 minutes and because I have very
little interest in debating the merits
of any programming language especially
not JavaScript and also because I like
to talk I'm going to talk for 40 minutes
and if I don't talk for 40 minutes we
might do a Q&A and that will be my
punishment for for not filling the whole
slot so yeah here we go with that said
if you do have questions at some point
during the presentation please do not
interrupt me and please save your
questions for never I'm totally kidding
you could talk to me anytime during the
conference
I'm I'm just nervous a Q&A is especially
nerve-wracking so um as I noted in the
in the abstract and it might have seen
in the program you should walk away from
this talk having a deeper appreciation
for the feat of human cooperation that
is the world wide web and how JavaScript
became one of its most important threats
however you will not walk away
having heard any clever opinions about
testing writing deploying and monitoring
code and you also won't learn any new
design patterns that you can take back
to work next week so if you're here it's
strange loop because you're eager to be
become a better software practitioner
this talk might not be the best use of
your time and I I genuinely will not be
offended if you decide to leave now or
at any point during the talk and while I
do think as software practitioners it's
critically important for us to
understand the historical context with
that our industry came out of and I
think this talk will be worth your time
I might also recommend another talk
that's going on right now for the folks
in the room who are here too because
they want to take away they want to
learn something practical and take it
back to work I might recommend the
observability talk happening happening
in the other venue Christine Yin is
giving that talk and she is the
co-founder of honeycomb honeycomb does
some really cool work around
observability and observability is a
concept a set of practices and goal
posts around monitoring our code and and
building better monitoring tooling so we
can understand when things go wrong and
when they go right it should be a really
great talk so while I can folks a chance
to decide if they want to stay or not
let me tell you a little bit about Who I
am and why you might be interested in
listening to me give this talk so hi I'm
Tara Bansal this is me I'm a software
engineer you can find me online in far
too many places I live and work in New
York City this is by far the most boring
introduction introductory slide I've
ever done but it really does fit for
where I'm at in my life I actually moved
across the country from Texas to New
York City this spring by myself so my
identity this summer has really revolved
around surviving in New York City
so this is really this is really Who I
am right now thank you for listening I
haven't had much time for hobbies this
summer but one I have had time for my
one hobby that I always make time for
which is doing nails I'm obsessed with
nails I actually have a full-blown
professional nail salon not really a
slot but you know what I mean in my
bedroom okay so if you're interested in
nails if you have questions about like
how to talk to your manicurist what to
ask for definitely talk to me I know
more than I ought to about nails okay so
I said I'm a software engineer and that
can mean a million different things what
that means for me is that I get paid to
write and maintain JavaScript know CSS
HTML sometimes I work with CSS more
often than I like I work with web pack
sometimes the write bash scripts and
honestly a lot of the time I write slack
messages
who knew that writing software involves
talking to people what a concept but I
want to highlight the technologies I
work with every day because I'm really
proud to say that I work on the web I
have chosen the web platform as my stack
that's not to say that I couldn't
couldn't be an infrastructure engineer
or I couldn't learn you know about
Haskell or list or whatever it's just
that I love the web and what it stands
for and I think it's such a phenomenal
platform for building things on and this
is a big part of who I am and why I'm
interested in giving this talk I'm
really looking to work at a place called
glitch that feels the same way about the
web glitch is a company that came out of
fog Creek which is the is the company
that made Stack Overflow and Trello so
it has this long history of helping
folks build stuff on the web and I'm
really proud to glitch for maintaining
that legacy today it's kind of tricky to
explain what glitches but I I
mostly like to highlight that it's a
code editor a code editor in the browser
that lets you collaborate with folks
just like you would with Google Docs and
deploys your app as you type so the
example that you see in this video is a
simple web page but you can build entire
applications with backends on glich as
well so we support no GIS and if you're
if you're a creative and ambitious you
can probably get it to support some
other languages too so I think glitch is
just like this super cool thing that
enables folks of all skill levels to
build on the web and I'm really proud to
be there this talk is not about glitch
and I I should say even though I will
mention it a few times in this talk
they're not paying me I mean like
they're paying me to do my job they're
not paying me to talk about glitch I
don't write code for free and you
shouldn't either before I worked at
glitch I worked on a project a
two-person team organ project called the
beaker browser beaker was a weird
project but it was really cool it was a
browser yeah two people made a browser
it what a concept
we built this browser with electrons so
we weren't you know building the innards
of the browser from the ground up we
were leaning on chromium we were leaning
on the folks on the electron team who
did all this fount fundamental work to
make it possible to build a browser with
JavaScript and HTML and CSS and node
it's really weird but we built a browser
because we wanted to run some
experiments we the two of us who worked
on it we loved the web and we think the
web is mostly great but it's got some
problems and because we were just two
people in an apartment we didn't really
have any power to leverage with
standards bodies so we thought well what
if we just changed the web and make it
work the way we want it to so we did the
main experiment that we ran was to put a
peer-to-peer protocol in the browser the
technical details don't really mat
matter here what matters
is what the end result was the end
result was that we were able to make it
easier for folks to click one button and
publish a website from the browser and
we we even built an in browser editor to
edit those websites so it's very similar
to glitch and it's it's not a
coincidence that I've worked on two
projects in a row that help folks
publish and edit web sites and it's I
say it's not a coincidence because it's
actually been very intentional I started
building on the web in a period where it
wasn't that easy to publish websites geo
city geo cities had long gone they'd
been shut down and taken like 30 million
some odd websites with it and glitch
didn't exist yet now didn't exist yet
and neither did net laugh I so when I
was learning how to code on the web I
struggled to publish the things I was
building on my local machine and I felt
that very deeply so I had to learn how
to like set up AWS and use Heroku and
all these things that a newbie
programmer probably shouldn't have to do
when they're just trying to learn the
fundamentals of base JavaScript but I
did it so when I you know years later I
I walk away feeling very certain that
it's important to take as many barriers
away for folks to participate on the web
and so that's why I'm so proud of the
work that it and I'm bigger and so proud
to be working at glitch if you'll let me
get a little bit sentimental if I
haven't already if you let me get a
little bit sentimental I want to spend
some time reflecting on what the web is
and and I want to do it on a really
grand scale and I especially want to
reflect on the values that are encoded
into the web whether they were
intentional or accidental because they
play a really big part in the argument
that I'm gonna try to make about why
javascript is so great so if you think
of it on the grandest longest scale the
web is sort of like it's the apex of
human communication just like the radio
or telegram
or telephones were once the pinnacle of
how we talk to each other as humans I
think of the web as the apex of human
communication today we have this shared
set of standards for getting information
from one computer to another that's
pretty cool if we would break it down
and to get into the more technical
details you might say that the web is a
standardized set of tools for
transmitting and interacting with
documents and the word tools is broad
here we're talking about the languages
that make up the web JavaScript HTML CSS
we're talking about browsers and the the
the protocols that they've all agreed to
implement in mostly the same way we're
talking about the bodies the standards
bodies that help shape these
specifications like the w3c and that
what WG it's massive the web is massive
and there's there's really no end to
where there's it's hard to say where the
web begins and where the web ends but
what's important to note is that we've
all agreed to use these same tools
so to summarize it I like to say that
the web is humanity's shared language
think about that for a second we
actually have a shared language for our
comfort for specifying how our computers
should talk to each other that is
profound it's messy but it's profound
and I think we shouldn't take it for
granted I think we really have to
appreciate that this is an incredible
feat of human cooperation an enormous
collective effort to build something
that that serves us all and if you step
back for a moment and think about how
bad humans are at cooperating with each
other it's a goddamn miracle that the
web is even here today I also like to
talk about the values that are encoded
into the web and some of these were on
purpose and some of them were accidental
the first is that the web
opened that means anybody can
participate you don't have to pay a fee
you don't have to ask for permission to
publish a website all you need to do is
follow the rules speak the language of
the web and you are welcome to
participate that doesn't mean it's
always easy you know like I said setting
up servers and running servers is not
easy that's why many of you in this room
get paid a lot of money to do it
learning hTML is not even easy it might
seem easy to some of us in this room
because we've been working with HTML for
a long time but it's not simple it takes
effort but it's important to know that
anybody can participate if they so
choose the web is also decentralized
which means it doesn't belong to any one
party not a government not Apple not
Google well Apple Google and some other
large corporations do have an outsized
influence on how it works and how it
evolves through standards bodies but
they don't own it we don't have to pay
Google 10 cents to decode every webpage
we visit we do see a lot of ads and
they're largely to blame for that but
still the the promise of shared
participation in this in this platform
is there and lastly the web is shared
because it doesn't belong to any one
party it belongs to all of us
and that's both a blessing and a curse
it belongs to all of us which means that
it's also our shared responsibility to
protect it to preserve it to deal with
all of its quirks and its inconveniences
and to fix it sorry
so I want to move into the next part of
the talk where I'm gonna try to convince
you that even though javascript has
flaws even though it's far from perfect
that it's actually okay and to be
expected and I think arguably even part
of the reason JavaScript has been so
successful
so before I do that I want to set some
expectations about how I'm gonna
approach this argument and I hope you'll
all come along with me so I hope we can
all agree that javascript is an
imperfect programming language all
programming languages are imperfect
JavaScript may be a bit more than the
rest but it's fine I hope we can also
agree that the web as a miracle and we
ought to preserve it just like democracy
is a miracle of human cooperation and we
have to fight for it every single day we
have to fight for the web every single
day lastly it's not that serious debates
about programming languages are all in
good fun especially in spaces like this
spaces that are dedicated to you know
grappling with each other over the the
intricacies of the tools we work with
but outside of this space debates about
programming languages are secondary to
what we build and who we're building for
so I would just like us to keep that in
mind and if we do end up having time for
Q&A especially keep this part in mind be
nice ok so my first argument is that it
doesn't make sense to judge JavaScript
in a vacuum to judge JavaScript solely
on the merits of its merits solely as a
programming language is to miss the
point and to accurately weigh its place
in the world you have to consider
JavaScript between type scope and syntax
in fact I'm not even gonna talk about
the intricacies what's wrong with
JavaScript in this talk because I don't
think it matters what matters is that
the web is the context in which
JavaScript operates the web is a social
space and because it's a social space
it's a political space so it's really
wasting our time to be arguing about the
mistakes that Brennan egg might have
made in the 10 days that he wrote
javascript because it's we're stuck with
it we have made our bed we have to lie
in it and we can't get rid of JavaScript
if we got rid of JavaScript we might
have to
we would have to accept that web pages
from 1990 and earlier and after would
not work and I think that's something
thankfully we were not willing to give
up about the web and the second thing I
want to argue today is that JavaScript
success is in part due to its flaws so
JavaScript if you don't know it's the
most popular programming language in the
world and it continues to grow year
after year in isolation it Swartz might
make it seem like it's kind of crummy
but in reality there part of why it's
been successful so this is data from
stack overflows 2019 developers survey
this is not like the holy source of
truth about programmers and the tools
that they use but I think it's a pretty
telling set of data so all respondents
said that out of all respondents sixty
seven point eight percent of them said
that they are using javascript and only
second behind that is HTML and CSS which
is also part of the web so javascript is
here to stay I mean even if these even
if these numbers aren't totally accurate
it makes sense to me that like tons of
programmers and non professional
programmers alike are using javascript
it's everywhere it's on your phones it's
in every browser it's in your
refrigerators it is in spreadsheets I'm
you mean like where isn't JavaScript
I would ask so it makes sense that it
would be this popular and I want to
reiterate that JavaScript was written in
10 days so it's gonna have some problems
and this is I'm this is why I don't
really want to get into the nitty-gritty
details of what's wrong with JavaScript
I think those of us in this room
probably know it doesn't have strong
support for for those of you who are
into types like JavaScript is not your
thing
comparing null and strings it's like
things get ugly really fast right and
we've learned
we've learned to work around it since
JavaScript was created because we had to
it was written in 10 days Brendan Eich
made our bed and here we are we couldn't
get rid of it because people were using
it we made a promise to ourselves into
the future the future humanity that we
were gonna make the web work for a long
time but that doesn't mean we can't fix
those problems javascript does have the
unusual constraints in that there are
tons of different clients implementing
javascript and sometimes choosing to
deviate from the from the specifications
maybe they deviate from the
specifications because well their Google
and they have outsized influence on the
web and they have a ton of users maybe
the browser a browser vendor just
doesn't have the resources to implement
a specification on the timeline that
they would like so I think we have to be
patient with JavaScript and when we when
we get frustrated with its drawbacks
that we understand that they can be
fixed it will just take time and it will
probably be messier than we'd like so I
would like to propose a thought
experiment and I would like I would like
to ask what if instead of JavaScript the
web used Haskell seriously like can you
imagine what the web have become the
canvas for creativity that it is today
would it be used in schools to introduce
kids to programming would we see the C C
the same shared commitment to preserving
this beautiful collective space we have
I would like to argue no I think it's
important that you can pick up
JavaScript and make mistakes with it I
think it's critical that you can start
typing in an HTML file and see the
changes live right away in your browser
I don't want to give that up even though
it does sometimes make my job harder
people are very mean to JavaScript
online it's
sad like I got really sad doing research
for this talk
you know there's folks on Stack Overflow
and Cora and all the other forums just I
think taking their frustrations about
JavaScript out on the people who choose
to work with JavaScript in their lives
people who are putting food on the table
for their families and helping build
their communities with the money they
make writing JavaScript I'm one of them
so I take it a little bit personally but
as a professional I know how to work
around the shortcomings of JavaScript
we've spent decades professionalizing
this industry and it's just really not
fair to say that javascript is a bad
language and I don't think we would we
would want a better language to take its
place anyway because I think the web
would be a much sadder place um I want
to highlight something that Tim
berners-lee wrote in 1998 he coined this
term called the principle of least power
well I'm not sure if he coined it but he
at least used it and in this document he
talked about how how important how he
felt it was so important to make sure
that we make our languages on the web
not as powerful as possible but to pick
the least powerful solution that works
so he was actually writing this document
about HTML and he was communicating why
he chose to make HTML so simple and
declarative and he wasn't specifically
speaking to JavaScript at this point but
I think it's I think it really holds up
when we talk about how when you when you
pick the least powerful but effective
solution you make sure that you keep the
gates open for a wide a wide variety of
folks
many years later Jeff Atwood
yeah
so Jeff Atwood was reflecting on this
this thing that Tim berners-lee wrote
and he interpreted the principle of
least power reinterpreted it and to said
that any application that can be written
in JavaScript will be written in
JavaScript I read this blog post of his
I truly don't follow how he got to this
even though I agree with him I think
like time has proven that any
application that could be written in
JavaScript will it will be done I don't
know how he got there I agree with him I
just wanted to roast him because he's
being a dingus on the internet right now
so yeah so Jeff Atwood doesn't
understand the desire to unionize and
technology why should you rich people
unionize you're all rich right
no most tech workers are not rich most
tech workers aren't even programmers
also collective action is a really
powerful tool that demands executives
acts and the best interest of the planet
and the people who live on it your boss
doesn't love you the good times might
not last and you should go to tech
workers coalition org okay
[Applause]
so the web is a mess but that's to be
expected the web is one of the weirdest
strangest things that humanity has ever
done but it's beautiful and we have to
protect it and even though it's a mess I
think it's really important to highlight
our successes to remember that it
doesn't all suck out there like there's
a lot of really talented people probably
some of you in this room who are putting
their lives and their effort and their
energy towards making the web better and
maybe like you don't have to you don't
have to commit your life to like
improving the web but I do ask that like
whatever you do with the web or with
code like just don't evil please um so
yeah I want to highlight some of the
amazing things that have happened on the
web bigot we're gonna be able to like do
better math and JavaScript soon so this
is still this is still in the works
like I said JavaScript moves slow
because you have a bunch of invested
parties that have to agree and argue and
then disagree and maybe agree later so
this stuff takes time but it's happening
right like this is gonna be really huge
right now
in order to do and to do like financial
mathematics and whatever I don't know
I'm not financed like there's we have to
use external libraries folks have to use
external libraries and people have
opinions about external libraries and
JavaScript I think one of the chief
complaints I've read while researching
this talk is that apps are bloated well
cool people who work in finance are
gonna be able to remove those library
libraries reduce parsing compile time
and it's gonna be great
then JavaScript will finally be perfect
I want to also talk about let's encrypt
I think this is one of the most
important things to happen on the web in
a really long time so it feels like a
long time ago that let's encrypt got
started for those of you who don't know
it is a free automated transparent
certificate authority run for the
public's benefit and what that means is
that you now can get
a TLS certificate for free they have
really great ways tools for automating
renewing those certificates and and what
this means in practice is that a ton
more people are deploying their websites
with HTTPS and that means that websites
are less prone to being manipulated by
jerks or nation-states or anyone just
trying to do nefarious things and it
just is so cool like it's free there
they're explicitly committed to to
making it free and transparent and to
benefit the collective that is the web
and finally just all of the cool [ __ ]
that's being built on the web every
single day seriously there's so much of
it so I have a really hard time job
tolerating JavaScript hatred because I
see people every day in my work
especially at glitch building beautiful
amazing things sometimes they're weird
and funny sometimes they're actually
useful but no matter what they're
important to somebody and I think that's
really special so if you'll allow me I
do just like want to highlight some of
these projects because they're are so
cool so you can get a picture of
spider-man cool
yeah that's oh that's a good one that's
from this the spider-verse which is like
one of the best spider-man's ever I want
to see Tom Holland where is yet nope
nope nope
oh wow did they leave out the best
spider-man they might have okay well
carry on this is another amazing project
that was built on glitch this person did
some really amazing stuff where you can
give the app access to your camera and
it will check your posture and blur your
screen when your posture looks bad so
let's I don't I don't know what standing
posture should look like
it's blurry so I guess I'm like hunching
my shoulders
okay I don't think you can have good
posture when standing I guess that's
guess that's how it works
and then finally soul patch upside down
soul patch this is my coworker
Cassie's cat Cassie made this amazing
web ring for pets on glitch and this
just highlights to me like the weird and
wonderful nature of what javascript in
the web allows like okay I'm gonna see
if I could here we go let's let's go to
a random another random pet website
because gosh pets are so good oh the app
has to wake up its tired you to um while
we're waiting for that to wake up why
don't I show you this really cool
Wikipedia game a lot of folks have been
making games on glitch sometimes they're
like lo-fi sometimes they're actually
real proper games I love this one it's
um it's like a follow follow the thread
for Wikipedia you start with one term
and you have to get to another term and
you know a certain amount of a tense so
let's do it
The Undertaker oh wow uh does anybody
know what the Undertaker is is that a
wrestling thing oh yeah it's got to be
okay
okay we got to get to basketball sports
entertainment that's easy enough
oh did you say Dennis Roy okay I hear
Harlem go times oh yeah here we go here
we go Oh second row boom we've done it
okay um let's let's try this again I'm
really hoping we get LOUIE LOUIE is my
other co-workers pet it's a dog oh no
this is a cat cat reviews of toys
adorable okay so people are building
stuff on the web and you can choose to
you can choose to criticize JavaScript
on its merits that's fine but please
keep your criticisms to the forums where
they're appropriate
looking down on folks who decide to
build web apps is it's just mean it's
boring not interesting find something
better to do with your time please and
also if you if you are someone who's
really into programming languages and
you have opinions and you have the
skills I encourage you to get involved
this is a the web is a shared effort and
where you need all the help that we can
get to make it better
tc39 is the body that defines
ACMA script which is the specification
that all the different browsers and like
VA and all all the folks who implement
javascript this is the specification
they're working off of and there's some
really amazing smart folks working here
and I I seriously encourage you to
consider participating if you have
concerns about JavaScript okay I want to
close with the title of a chapter of a
book called beautiful JavaScript written
by my boss Jen Schiffer called one world
one language and if you know Jen you
know she's a bit of a jokester but she's
really I think she's really serious here
one world one love one language whatever
and I think this to me encapsulate so
much of what I feel about JavaScript
which is that it is precious it's
seriously so precious because of where
it sits in our shared experience learn
to love it or eat its dust honestly
thank you
[Applause]
we have six minutes I might take like
one or two questions I'm feeling I'm
feeling wild yeah yeah I don't I did not
use Comic Sans in here I hope I didn't
mean to if I did yeah what is the
favorite thing I've build JavaScript uh
do I know the stupidest thing I've built
with JavaScript okay um I'm really sorry
this is like sort of PG I don't know so
this is definitely the stupidest thing
I've ever built it is you upload a photo
like I don't know let me just pick this
one to Beyonce and you can these are
male nipples so don't get offended I
don't I don't know how to manage my time
I also built I also built a full-blown
emoji picker for this damn thing so like
you know you can actually like change
the skin color um by the way github
doesn't even do this I do so get it
together github I build a lot of stupid
stuff but that's fine I'm allowed to
okay uh we have yeah we have a little
bit more time yeah I don't know I don't
really read JavaScript books
I honestly learned from mdn the Mozilla
developer Network that's like my
favorite javascript website ever because
it's also an open source website anyone
can contribute and also they have a
proper team dedicated to maintaining it
so just like read those pages they they
do a good job of balancing technical
like just reiterating what the
specification is about let's say arrays
but they also do an amazing job of
providing tutorials that step you
through
how to actually use the fetch API or how
to actually you know turn on your camera
the users camera and it happens it's
great no more questions
oh we got one more what are my thoughts
on wasum I think it's a dope I think
it's so cool I have I don't know
anything like about how to write it but
I know people that I really respect are
super excited about it because it it
allow it cooperates with the web right
what's it's not changing the web it's
not breaking the web it's just saying
hey let's make the web more powerful so
I'm all for it in fact if there are any
woes and talks here today or tomorrow I
would definitely will be going alright I
think I'm gonna wrap it up thank you so
much for coming